hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled hmgb1
to help
in the understanding of covid19 disease
this webinar is part of the 2021
microbiology virtual week and i'm susie
valdez of labyrinth and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and sponsored by tcan for more
information about tcan go to www
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during this
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of our presentation
also if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click
box located on the far left of your
screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right hand corner of your
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits
without further ado i now present
today's speaker dr alt anderson a
professor of pediatric rheumatology at
carolina institute for a complete
biography of our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr anderson welcome you may now
begin
my name is ulf anderson
i have worked as a professor in
pediatric rheumatology for many years at
the carolina hospital in
stockholm and at the same time
i have performed
basic research
in the context of
cytokines
and the last 20 years in the context of
hnb1 and the cholinergic
anti-inflammatory
pathway
at
the careers institute
in stockholm
[Music]
asian iran is probably the most
studied molecule
in the
alarm system
uh when we talk about alarmist and damn
signals
um each one is is in focus
it is a nuclear
protein present in all cells
when a cell
gets
in trouble or threatened or even dying
then h1 will be released as an
inflammatory
signal
analytic cell death will cause hm1
the extracellular release the second
pathway for h1 to get extracellular is
via active secretion and that happens in
many different
cells
which are activated or stressed
once h1 is extracellular as a
alarm signal it uses two different
receptor
systems
to induce inflammation hd1 is generally
complex bound extracellular
with other molecules like dna rna
histones nucleosomes endotoxin il1 alpha
alvan beta and other
danger molecules
and these complexes will bind to rage
the consequence of this is endocytosis
and the complexes will first end up in
endosomes and later in the
system normally
lysosomes will get degraded
but the unique thing with hd1 is that it
works like a detergent in high intra
lysosomal concentrations
and that will mean that the lysosomes
will be damaged and that will enable
hiv-1 partner molecules access
to the cytosol
and access to sensors for
for these molecules and that's the
background why hnb1 may be so
dangerous in
in
covid
[Music]
talking about respiratory viral
infections i think influenza and rsp
virus don't you like this or the best
studied
viral infections
and
what has been found is that
systemic levels of h and dv1 are
detected and correlate to the severity
of
of
the the
pneumonia or here like this
we know that this is an olympic
viral infection in epithelium cells
in in the respiratory threat that means
excessive cell death
and that by
definition means that h1 will be
extracellularly
released
and
then you get secondary inflammation and
active
secretion
by
by inflammatory cells adding to the
adding ancient neuron
additionally to the extracellular pool
so asian one must be around in huge
amounts in in the lungs
in in severe
disease
another important fact is that it has
been shown that the arterial
concentration of
hdb1 is only 60 percent of that found in
venus blood
in in that samples taken simultaneously
that means that a substantial pool of h1
is retained in in the pulmonary
circulation rates can be induced in
inflammation in many other cell systems
but if we look
at it as a physiological situation then
the lungs
are the only organ that has
a
rage expressed
um on cells
on the surface
so i think
that the purpose of this is for rage
in the lungs to eliminate north ancient
iran itself but
complexes of hnpb1 that is the
the danger molecules that hd1 are
complex with extracellularity
like dna rna
lps and and
and other
unwanted um extracellular molecules
they under physiological circumstances
they will
get to the lungs and be then eliminated
in the lysosomes but if you have huge
amounts of these complexes and huge
amounts of
um intralysosomal h and db1 then you get
damage
to the lysosomes which may then enable
these um
potentially dangerous molecules
like dna on rna and histones and
nucleosomes and and lps to get into the
cytosol
[Music]
i think
this goes both
for the cytokine storm and for the
clothing catastrophe
which are both
so
harmful events in severe
clothing i want to add
one
recently
identified factor to this
pathogenetic scenario and that is that
patients
who have severe covalent they have
detectable source
cov2
rna
fragments of of rna in the circulation
that can be detected for three weeks
um
extracellular layer
um
at the same time
this oxford group who published the
paper could never find
infectious
intact variants in circulation only in
the
respiratory tract
as long as rna is extracellularly it is
probably rather unharmful
but the moment that h1 enables this rna
to get
intracellular to the cytosol
where where
there are sensors for rna like big eye
and
other molecules then
then they may very well take part of the
pathogenesis we know that
inflammasome activation
ends with a cleavage of a molecule
called gastermin d
which is a poor for poor forming
molecule but it has another
also important mission and that is to
translocate the
phosphatidylserine that is inside the
cell
membrane to the outer side of the cell
surface
in an
inverted
shape
and that phosphatidylserine
is a perfect perfect ligand to
tissue factor the molecule that starts
the
extrinsic
coagulation system
the combination that
h and db1
transported molecules will
get
phosphatidylserine expressed on cell
surfaces and hd1 via atoll 4 and an nf
kappab activation will up regulate
tissue factor on endothelial cells and
on
macrophages and
cells
is
a very dangerous situation that will
cause
population
i want to point to
one
one fact that that has intrigued me a
lot and that that is that there are a
lot of
unusual
neurological manifestations in in code
and
one fact is that
smokers
are partially protected from the severe
form of choline
and it's very likely that it is the
nicotine
that is the active molecule here
and
nicotine
acts via nicotinic
acetylcholine receptors
and
that points them to the autonomic
nerve system
as as being a
disturbed uh
system in in syria covered we know that
there is something called the
cholinergic um
anti-inflammatory pathway that is
mediated via acetylcholine
and that
and we know that the vagus system is
central for for this
neural control of inflammation
and the fact that
nicotine
helps to prevent too much cyclical
information indicates that
there is an autonomic dysfunction
in severe
coving the cholinergic and inflammatory
system does not
work properly
here is really a paradox i mean if you
check pubmed you will find
around 50 000
hits on if you print kobe 19
but if you
if you try to find
studies
where they have measured hd1 in kobe 19
you will find one such study so far
and and
and
that study found increased level of 81
but this is really a
paradox we have tried to
that is so successful in in all other
diseases we have tested
to
to measure hd1 in in severe covetations
and the remarkable finding that we have
come to is that we don't find increased
level of hnu1
even in patients who have crp of several
hundred
units
um
we we find this
unlikely to to reflect the true
biology i mean you have massive cell
death you have massive inflammation
we are we know that the
this
is our conditions which always
generate increased systemic hd1 levels
so
we
suspected
that the elisa antibodies could not
detect hd1 because there were molecules
uh attached to
hnb1 i mean the way that i have
discussed before that in the evo h1
binds so many
extracellular danger molecules like
nuclear nucleic acids uh lps and and and
other molecules what we then
did is that we used perchloric acid as a
very harsh treatment in order to
pre-treat the plasma samples to
try to dissociate
possible molecules that were attached to
hdb1
and that turned out to be the case when
we did this pre-treatment and we found
high levels of hn1 in systemically in in
patients with severe cobalt despite the
fact that this
tough three feet and also must have
damaged some of the h neuron molecules
so we
anyhow found
strongly increased h1 levels
we have confirmed this by using western
blot analysis too
but
there is obviously a major problem here
in kobe that molecules attach to ancient
environment yeah and and and these are
so hardly uh bound that the conventional
buffer step that is always used in in
the in the
[Music]
they can elisa
procedure does not work to
to
dissociate the the the molecules
thank you
thank you thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you